[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport les saisons changent nous
sommes au printemps mais il ya bien une
chose qui ne change pas c'est le concept
de ce talk il y aura comme d'habitude
des analyses des débats et des tués duel
va scharner sur l'actualité sportive du
département avec nos chroniqueurs
aujourd'hui ils sont cinq
autour de la table présentation en
musique on commence à ma droite cds sur
les sur les terrains de rugby avec
versailles dans nos studios c'est un
véritable combattant le froid les gelées
de l'hiver ne lui ont pas fait peur ou
seule seconde
d'ailleurs c'est souvent balader dans
les rues vers ses aises avec juste une
peau de bête sur le dos on le surnomme
dans cette émission le gladiateur pierre
chevallier du rugby-club de versailles
est avec nous on sortir mickaël salut a
tous formés bonheur alors ce cette
histoire de peaux de bêtes dans les rues
de versailles ont fait 1 c'est une
légende une rumeur les gens n'ont rien
de la bi est bon pour une peau de bête
jeter comme ça négligemment ça fait
passer l'hiver temps qu'elle ok on prend
ça au lot on passe à ma gauche musique
c'est une petite nouvelle dans cette
émission qu'elle deviendra bientôt
incontournable elle nous vient tout
droit de viroflay et c'est l'une des
meilleurs coachs sportifs du département
elle est aussi experte en nutrition je
vais d'ailleurs lui demander quelques
conseils à la fin de l'émission pour
perdre un petit peu de pourra en vue de
l'été les célébres arrête avec nous
quand allez-vous les semis pour cette
grande première
pas trop stressé non non non je sais que
je viens à me voir à tout va n'hésitez
pas à demander quelques conseils à
pierre chevalier ainsi il faut encore
une mission on repasse à ma droite
musique il est dans mon coeur
si on sait l'un des meilleurs
chroniqueurs de l'histoire de ce
remaniement le sauna bleus zorro yves
binois dans ce talk
le cavalier international de plaisir le
seul l'unique
l'incroyable raul que très d'autres et
nous fait l'honneur de venir sur ce
plateau
bonjour comment allez vous très bien
ravi de vous retrouvez donc c'est un
retour aux sources
ici ah oui je suis très content voilà il
ya des nouvelles têtes ont paradé leur
folle et si par exemple il avait dans
l'émission voit la super voilà pouvoir à
vie en tout cas repasse à ma gauche
musique magique
éblouissant époustouflant des
superlatifs utilisés principalement sur
les affiches des plus gros blockbusters
américains des termes utilisés également
pour qualifier les prestations de ce
chroniqueur devenu mythique dans les
yvelines coach genlis ex-entraîneur de
plaisir plus du plaisir rugby club est
avec nous pendant une heure bonsoir
michael et vos soir à tous bonjour quand
allez-vous agents impeccable toujours en
forme
ah mais moi toujours toujours dit que je
viens ici je suis bien j'ai retrouvé
tout le monde sait très bien
voilà vous avez le retour de raul aussi
retour de deux euros ça fait bien
plaisir de le voir
impeccable on termine à ma droite
musique c'est seulement son deuxième si
on parlait sport il sera notre
spécialiste football dans cette émission
c'est un chroniqueur niveau ligue des
champions plus fort que le retourné
acrobatique de cristiano ronaldo contre
la juventus de turin
georges gomis président du plaisir
sporting club est avec nous bonjour
georges
bonjour a tous très envie de
vous retrouver on va passer une
excellente après-midi je suppose et tout
le talent de des uns et des autres alors
vous êtes plus fort que le retourné
acrobatique de cristiano ronaldo contre
la juventus de turin à 8x eu la leur
tournée je pourrais je pense pas être à
la hauteur de dû retourner à cristiano
mais je vais essayer de 10mg haut niveau
pour mon enfant pour moi ont approché un
petit peu alors nous allons maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
football et de la victoire au bout du
suspense de maurepas face à plaisir en
demi-finale de la coupe des ivy nous
évoquerons également la boxe et la
défaite de l'élan courtois a dit lahm ou
m'a dit une contre performance qui
pourrait lui coûter à lui barrer le
chemin du titre mondial
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
ouvre une page bmx la première manche de
la coupe du monde de bmx s'est tenue ce
samedi 31 mars et ce dimanche 1er avril
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines avec les meilleurs pilotes
du monde en activité
une première depuis sept ans en france
l'événement a été suivi par plus de dix
mille spectateurs une ambiance des
grands jours qui a sublimé les pilotes
français selon le staff des tricolores
on écoute le coach juin sastre au micro
de nicolas landry dirais que c'est un
petit plus en terme de motivation et
d'enthousiasmé ça nous fait toujours un
immense plaisir de courir à domicile
c'est à une saveur un peu particulière
donc donc oui je dirais que oui on a un
petit comme on dit en anglais comme
advantage le pilote qui est le plus
profité de cet avantage à domicile c'est
lui joris daudet le pilote du stade
bordelais 2 fois vainqueur de la
couronne mondiale en 2011 et 2016 a
terminé troisième de la première manche
le samedi et 1er 24 heures plus tard
écoutez sa réaction je suis vraiment
content de gagner ici à la maison à
paris c'est vraiment exceptionnel le
public est exceptionnel tout le week-end
donc merci et j'espère qu'on aura une
autre coupe du monde ici en france l
année prochaine
genre vous pensez que ça motive encore
plus devant son public
forcément c'est un plus oui bien sûr
c'est à dire c'est souvent dans les
sports collectifs 17,2 le 16e en mots
rubicon il est là au bmx c'est forcément
on veut on veut faire le mieux et en
naîtra du cndd et de 26 en public c'est
normal pia n'y a pas une part de chance
un peu dans le bmx c'est pas forcément
le meilleur qui gagne à chaque fois je
sais c'est a priori un sport où ça joue
au coude à coude et la force de la force
des mollets facteur chance facteur
chance sûrement un petit peu comme dans
tous les sports il faut que les planètes
sont alignées sur l' avantage de jouer à
domicile en saurons plus d'avoir son
public et ses proches
il ya sûrement aussi une notion de
repères connaître la piste et connaître
à connaître en gros les moindres les
moindres recoins et moindre virage qui
donne là aussi un avantage en plus
compliqué facteur chance les gens c'est
un bel événement au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 10000
spectateurs je disais au niveau du
public le public a répondu présent
je pense que ça prouve l'engouement qui
a pour ce sport cette discipline au
niveau départemental et que ce soit un
garçon du département qui viennent
gagner chez soi c'est jamais facile mais
avec un bon public dix mille personnes
c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus simple
et beaucoup plus motivant de pouvoir
gagner chez soi et comme le disait et
repères c'est important parce que le
moindre virage le moindre creux va vous
le connaissez pas ce que vous entraîner
sur la piste
moi je suis très ravi pour ce pour le
sport et pour pour le département et
pour ce garçon la question est de savoir
si le vélodrome est prêt ou pas
accueillir les jo de 2024 après cette
compétition
nouveauté c'est la question sur ce thème
oui ou non
oui oui oui oui les si je vous ai vu
brandir votre petit panneau vers rabat
ou pas ce que dit perd dix mille
personnes c'est déjà bien donc pour les
géo je pense que ils sont prêts et que
c'est d'ailleurs une très bonne nouvelle
raul vous si vous êtes d'accord pour
reprendre le propos de l'essai ou et dix
mille personnes pour 1 pour un sport qui
connaît une couverture médiatique quasi
nulles ce que le bmx longtemps sinon
jamais parlé c'est vrai que c'est un
score impressionnant après il ya un
petit bémol affectivement je crois que
les épreuves de bmx elles n'auront pas
lieu soul vélodrome
exact c'est un problème au niveau
olympique c'est qu'il faut pouvoir
filmer les épreuves
une vue aérienne donc ça sera dans un an
que simpson de mettre juste à côté dans
un terrain vague qui va être aménagée
pour exacto pour la gloire de 50 ans
divine à l'hameçon 250 mètres la piste
actuelle qui a accueilli les épreuves de
la coupe du monde apparemment justement
s'offrir une épreuve de d'autant plus on
voit les images horribles qui
accueillera les radios les épreuves de
bmx mais ouais maintenant je pense que
tu as ont fait un complexe qui a qui a
fait ses preuves à de l'entreprise donc
puis reste encore maintenant six ans
pour se préparer encore donc ça vient
pas de doute genre vous aussi vous êtes
d'accord avec eric raul oui tout à fait
oui c'est vrai dire c'est une bonne
boîte est une bonne répétition pour voir
un petit peu
comment une telle organisation avec des
places et dix mille à dix mille
spectateurs c'est beau c'est très bon
pour une pochette du premier porte
quelle discipline d'ailleurs donc ça ça
montre qu'ils sont prêts que les
infrastructures sont prêtes
même si à côté pour moi c'est une bonne
répétition pour eux à la vue des
prochains jeux organisés en france mais
ça sera pas forcément la piste qui c'est
pas la crise pour les j simplement de
l'organisation autour
ils ont ils ont montré qu'ils étaient
capables de faire l événement autour du
bmx avec un peu à venir dix mille
personnes
donc je pense que pour eux c'est une
belle répétition il ya on en a souvent
parlé ici il ya une ferveur dans le
département déjà pour ce sport
particulier pour le vélo et pour le bmx
qui ce qui qui est ce pour quoi le
l'endroit a été fait mais il ya aussi il
ya eu aussi beaucoup d'événements qui
ont été accueillis au sein du vélodrome
on a encore eu encore une fois soit en
parler à la fois agent port 2015 les
championnats du monde de handball on a
emmené par les motos il n'y a pas très
longtemps donc je crois que de toute
façon ils sont ils sont prêts à la
partie logistique organisation et
réponse du public donc a priori en plus
il reste il reste pas mal de temps pour
adapter adapter la structure à aux
exigences olympique
pourquoi ils se comprennent on se
tromperait des charges comme le disent
et mes collègues c'est une belle
répétition et ça va emmener autant de
public pour un événement similaire
je pense que bon on peut on peut peut
multiplier le nombre de spectateurs pour
les jo donc je pense que vu le terrain
je pense qu'ils vont vouloir un peu plus
grand
je pense pas que la dimension publique
bon je pense qu'ils vont faire un beau
stadion qui va pouvoir accueillir un
nombre important de public puisque là
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
on a on est quand même un département
vélo que le stadium devrait faire 7000
places à peu près 1 sur l'île de loisirs
de 57 milles places 7e place et n'a pas
dans les plans définitifs devraient
faire cette façon on peut pas intervenir
mais quand on voit qu'on peut accueillir
18 personnes fait 3018 ça va faire des
déçus et étant donné que ces régions en
tant que je pense qu'on pourrait
accueillir beaucoup plus de monde
et après après les géo il faut que ça
serve et c'est vrai que si on voit trop
grande
derrière on se retrouve avec un 1
comment un terrain fin stade la piste de
bmx vtt monté après me semble-t-il
alors la piste de bmx l'habituel sur
lesquels ces légers pas le coup de
julien de bmx restera quoi qu'il arrive
ça sera une piste d'entraînement pour
les athlètes qui participeront aux
épreuves sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines et ensuite la piste
qui servira aux épreuves de djo devrait
normalement être déplacé en fin de match
de démonter et remonter voilà ce que
prévu du site ce qui est prévu
initialement dans le projet est-ce qu'il
faudra laisser organiser d'autres
compétitions de ce type comme la coupe
du monde de bmx dans les prochaines
années
c'était une première depuis sept ans est
ce qu'il faudrait organiser une tous les
ans jusqu'en 2024
ouais c'est vrai que ce serait beaucoup
enfin ce serait beaucoup mieux pour
apporter plus d'attractivité au lieu qui
est pas très connu on est un peu
excentré de paris donc je pense que ce
serait vraiment très bien
après je me demande quand ce sera les jo
ce sera peut-être un public plus large
et là je sais pas comment ils sont
débrouillés pour les parkings parce que
dans l'émission du lundi par là du fait
que ça manquait beaucoup de places de
parking que dans il n'y a pas que le
nouveau terrain de bmx à reconstruire il
ya aussi tout un
un grand parking à refaire il faudrait
selon vous créer des parkings
supplémentaires
abbas est prévu c'est pas moi c'est
prévu c'est prévu donc après il ya quand
même
en termes d'organisation du travail quoi
donc faut pas non plus que ça perturbe
les travaux il faut pas se reposer sur
ses lauriers r si je comprends bien
non mais disons que je pense que c'est
plus compliqué que ça avait plus faim
qui a quand même du travail avant la
date d'effet au pire chouaieb d'accord
avec les six il faut organiser tous les
ans des compétitions de ce type les
compétitions internationales
et justement pour tester le pour tester
le l'appétence et pour tester la
possibilité d'organiser des grands
événements monté en montée en puissance
jusqu'au jusqu'au giro et puis justement
tester tester ses besoins logistiques le
côté transports s'est tu as été un
cetain une vraie question il ya un vrai
sujet à chaque fois qu'un événement
d'ampleur mondiale est organisée donc
plus ils auront l'occasion de se tester
à grandeur nature mondiale un mieux
mieux ce sera après ce qu'ils en auront
la possibilité par rapport à un
calendrier international ça c'est une
autre question mais ils peuvent encore
en tout état de cause candidater pour le
mot de la fin pour pierre chevallier sur
cette thématique hameau de football à
présent jouer ce dimanche 1er avril les
demi-finales de la coupe des yvelines
maurepas s'est imposé sur le terrain de
plaisir dans une ambiance électrique
je vous fais le déroulé de la rencontre
plaisir venez à 2 à 0 à cinq minutes de
la fin du match les plaisirs wa encaisse
deux buts et son pouce à une terrible
séance de tirs au but
on écoute les réactions du gardien juste
après l'égalisation
c'est super dur ça te met un coup au
moral on dit 2 0 il reste même pas de
trois minutes on se prend en main de
deux annonces à main koroma un coup au
moral mais voilà prenons-les ont essayé
d'être commentées professionnels et
garder la tête haute et georges en les
commandant sa tête après un scénario
comme celui là déjà on est on est très
déçu
je pense que ils ont bon déjà ils ont
une bonne réaction parce que
généralement on peut aussi y avoir avoir
un sentiment de comment d'injustice
parce que va mais en sport et cylia
possible pas le comment s'il n'ya pas le
la fin du match tout est possible pour
l'adversaire donc il avait tous les
ingrédients pour gagner ils ont place en
prendre à eux mêmes
mené au score à dix minutes de la fin en
ayant dominé un match un match n'est
jamais fini et je pense que le sentiment
c'est une grosse déception des tarifs
est si près du but et de se retrouver
d'avoir pris de but enfin 2-7 coups de
pied arrêtés dans le match puisqu'il ya
eu deux coups francs et cinq pénalités
voilà donc je pense que là il attendre
l'année prochaine pour pouvoir vivre
cette aventure c'est une faute
professionnelle gens à votre avis
d'avoir encaissé deux buts en cinq
minutes et le photo professionnelle s'il
est peu commun sans leur parler comme ça
parce que leur niveau niveau district
qui sont loin d'être professionnel je
pense que la déception de largement
suffire c'était leur maître pour le club
alors mettre le moral à zéro
c'était une coupe importante et une
coupe importante ça peut garnir la
vitrine du fait de la coupe au mic et la
coupe des yvelines et le groupe van
damme mais comme je dis souvent c'est la
fin du bal qu'on peut alors qu'istres
tels que le coup de sifflet final à
porte à dix le match n'est pas terminé
il faut jouer jusqu'à là au coup de
sifflet final
et là ils ont payé les frais c'est sûr
qu'il peut ils peuvent se les mordre les
doigts mais
les voilà il faut jouer face qu'ils
menaient 2-0 que c'était fait la preuve
et on l'a vu on l'a vu à n'importe quel
niveau
de toute façon dans les derniers on l'a
vu même à haut niveau
le psg contre barcelone il ya deux ans
où il avait d'ailleurs on a un gardien
derrière ce coup là oui c'est vrai c'est
il ya deux championnats d'europe de
coupe d'europe
exact et l'année dernière voilà donc à
tous les niveaux on y voit il faut jouer
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'au coup de sifflet
final alors dans quel état d'esprit
devait être l'entraîneur va travailler à
pierre chevalier fumasse je pense c'est
un scénario un peu dramatique c il ya
une différence de niveau de district
entre les deux équipes les moins bien
classées mène tout le match jusqu'à dix
minutes de la fin se faire rejoindre
c'est peut-être là aussi qu'on parle
d'expérience
quel raisonnement paillat il ya cru
jusqu'au bout a planté ses deux buts et
puis gagne gagner sur l'ascendant
psychologique avec après la séance de
tirs au but les mêmes même ans et c'est
un scénario de coupe scénario de coupe
même quel que soit le niveau de cette
coupe départementale seddaoui si on
prend de l'expérience c'est là aussi on
prend des on prend des grandes vagues de
déception dans l'est dans les gencives
et je pense que là ils doivent ressasser
encore mais voilà leur sa part de
responsabilité quand même pour vous il
aurait dû baisser leurs dépenses
là il a sa part de responsabilité moi je
suis pas j'étais pas au match je vais
pas vous dire ce qu'il aurait dû faire
on pas faire mais il a sa part
responsabilités on peut pas on peut pas
écrire il est là et rejeter la faute que
sur les joueurs
l entraîneur il a sa part responsabilité
dans la gestion de sa fin de match
ou bien il se fait remonter de deux buts
alors qu'ils ont le match mais donc lui
aussi à sa part la stabilité qui peut il
peut se mettre elle amènera les joueurs
on va écouter en tout cas la réaction du
défenseur de l'équipe le capitaine de
l'équipe au micro de nicolas gendry
scénario du match fait que c'est encore
plus c'est encore plus de bonheur
égalisent à la dernière seconde après
les tirs au but sur la loterie un peu
mais ça fait trois fois qu'on passe aux
tirs au but donc on peut dire qu'on
conduit assez à l'aise dans l'exercice
finalement dans l'autre demi-finale du
en cours s'est imposé à 5 1 face à
hardricourt les deux équipes de d1 de
district se rencontreront le 3 juin
prochain à maisons laffitte
la question sur ce thème l'équipe de
maurepas mérite elle sa qualification en
finale
oui ou non voter oui oui vous êtes
unanimes sur la question vous avez été
un peu timorés mitigé dans votre
décision genre pourquoi
non je peux dès maintenant je peux et et
tu vois là j'aurais juste la couleur
j'ai des problèmes avec la couleur fut
daltonien mais non non pas du tout et
ils l'ont pas volée il c'est pas eux qui
l'ont volé il sait pas une erreur ils
n'ont pas bénéficié d'une erreur
d'arbitrage donc pas bénéficier de il
leur victoire ne souffre d'aucune
contestation donc ici ils aurient sur le
final et ils l'ont pas volé non donc
brûler s'ils n'ont pas volé ah oui je
suis mais je suis tout à fait d'accord
non j'ai rien à ajouter et quand voilà
justement le contenu du match y perdre
2-0 en sachant que c'est une équipe
quand même au repas qui était une
division au dessus des plaisirs wwa est
ce qui n'est pas une part de déception
quand même d'attendre la dernière
seconde pour remporter la victoire
si bien évidemment mais c'est le jeu
comme on dit
donc je suis pas d'un tempérament
défaitiste alors je n'ai rien à ajouter
j'accepte voilà le scénario et puis
voilà quoi quoi qu'il arrive sont
qualifiés ouais mental il le mérite il
le mérite sur la gestion la gestion du
match youri même si hier il mène 6-1 en
décalage de niveau entre les deux
équipes y avoir cru jusqu'au bout et
puis comme disait comme disait jean
c'est vraiment jusqu'au coup de sifflet
final que que le destin se lient et se
délient et là en l'occurrence il le
mérite
il leur revient sûrement sur cette
dimension mentale d'avoir été le
chercher alors qu'ils étaient quand même
bien mal embarquée mais c'est pas
forcément ouvrir
est-ce que est-ce que c'est considérer
que parce qu'ils ont un district de plus
il aurait dû il aurait dû mener et puis
faire en sorte que ce soit eux qui
mènent 2-0 pendant tout le match
c'est là aussi où c'est au scénario de
scénarios de coupe c'est ils se sont pas
facilité la tâche c'est parce qu'on
attendait mais offrir au final même si
ça fait trois fois qu'il passe aux tirs
au but il pas ce genre je vais diriger
répondent à pierre ah ben ça me va juste
que l'histoire ne retient que le
résultat alors ok jamais la manière donc
le résultat est là et c'est ce que
retiendra l'histoire mais quand on joue
bol quand on joue au football la manière
nous permet de gagner plus souvent que
le résultat parce que la manière si on
joue dix fois bien je pense pas qu'on
perd cette fois alors que si on joue dix
fois mal on gagnera peut-être deux fois
mille fois par son parcours par contre
on peut dire aussi une chose on fait des
rues on peut dire une chose les coups de
pied arrêtés
l'importance des coups de pied arrêtés
aujourd'hui on débloque les matches on
débloque les matchs par les coups de
pied arrêtés
donc je pense que maurepas doit y
accorder beaucoup de temps et gueye
passé trois fois aux tirs au but face à
des adversaires bah c'est pas on peut
pas dire que c'est de la chance c'est la
technique c'est beaucoup de travail sur
les coups de pied arrêtés
bon peut-être que là ils sont sortis ils
sont sortis vainqueurs mais en football
on nous fait toujours ce qu'on a fait
aux autres alors j'attends le prochain
match pour voir si l'équipe adverse le
remettra peut-être un coup de pied
arrêté à la 90e minute donc un match
contre contre lui encourt cette finale
qui est favori sur l'envoi georges sur
cette rencontre les deux équipes jouent
dans la même division
bayon concours a remporté le dernier
match le match aller c'était pour boire
pas finalement les deux équipes sont
assez similaires dans leur jeu et à ses
proches au niveau les niveaux et gazière
qu'oman une finale de toute façon c'est
particulier déjà ça va se jouer sur
terrain neutre
une autre chose l'état de forme des
garçons parce que
on va arriver en fin de saison est ce
que est ce que la préparation physique
avait été fait de quelle manière
moi je donnerai plus tôt comment
l'avantagent l'équipe la moins bien
classée parce que l'équipe la moins bien
classée 6e enfin si elle est si elle est
assez régulier pour moi du en cours
puisque j'ai en cours
non je parle qui est actuellement 2e et
voilà pour qui j'ai joué mon cinquième
là je pense que l'équipe qui aura plus
de fraîcheur
l'argument course ils sont bien calés
dans le tank re ventre mou du creux du
championnat je pense que la leur finale
ils vont pouvoir la préparer comme il
faut alors les deux équipes s'étaient
affrontées en demi finale de coupe des
yvelines c'était il ya deux ans
maurepas l'avait emporté aux tirs au but
encore une fois raul est ce que ça va
être présent dans les esprits des
joueurs
a votre avis il a forcément je pense que
oui
pour moi on est toujours sur le souvenir
de la de la rencontre précédente même si
elle date on s'en souvient et on redoute
toujours les difficultés que l'on a fait
face dans dans les matches précédents
jean le coach peut s'en servir peut-être
deux
cette défaite il ya deux ans à maurepas
dans cette demi-finale de coupe désigne
pour préparer son match
oui deux ans deux ans et à la fois court
est longue mais on n'est pas sûr qu'ils
se soient là même le même groupe la même
équipe et c'est un impact sur sur le
collectif moi je vais tendance à dire
que
une finale pour en avoir joué plusieurs
en tant que joueur et entraîneur
ça ne se joue pas ça se gagne et c'est
tellement vrai parce que ce jour là mais
c'est avec les tripes qu'il faut aller
la chercher la victoire et pas seulement
parce que là on a eu les deux équipes
qui sont du même niveau
donc ce sera vraiment patiemment le
technique qui va faire la différence
mais les tripes et le mental ça sera le
mot de la fin sur cette thématique
football
après cette large page résultat nous
repassait à notre coup de projecteur
dans notre coup de projecteur de la boxe
c'est une déception dans le championnat
wba super-moyens l'élan courtois adila
hamouma 10 s'est incliné aux points ce
vendredi 30 mars à levallois face à
nadjib mohammedi à l'unanimité des trois
juges une défaite qui devrait priver le
sportif illinois d'un combat pour un
titre mondial à l'issue de la rencontre
adil hamouma 10 37 ans a demandé une
revanche ce qu'il pourrait obtenir selon
nos informations la question sur ce
thème
est ce que c'est la fin de la carrière
daddy la mauve a dit je vous rappelle
qu'il a 37 ans partage et pierre fait un
petit duel entre vous jean et georges
vous comment ces gens ce que george est
un bon pilote en malaisie dont je suis
mitigé parce que oui forcément
forcément c'est partir en boxe là le
fait de perdre un combat alors quand on
vise un titre mondial
c'est vraiment un arrêt important dans
la progression vers le combat pour le
titre mondial donc c'est c'est un petit
bémol
et puis à l'âge aussi on a déjà parlé
plusieurs fois sur ce plateau 37 ans et
37 ans
maintenant c'est pas possible c'est pour
ça que j'étais un petit peu mitigé c'est
pas possible parce que mais c'est un
boxeur qui a un mental énorme et qui la
montrait déjà plusieurs reprises et que
déjà s'il veut s'il veut une revanche
rapidement équivalent obtenir un vrai
simplement ça peut aussi dire à
certaines personnes
non je suis pas fini et je peux encore
prétendre à obtenir le titre mondial
voilà pourquoi j'ai été mitigée
desgeorges de toute façon bon après on
ne sait pas mais je pense qu'il va
falloir qu'on lui qu'on lui donne sa
chance déjà parce que là de repos que
c'est bon il a pas perdu par ko il a
perdu coups au point et moi
personnellement un stage aulas il a
perdu aux points certes mais il a quand
même perdu 118 110 sur l'un des juges
119-109 et 119-109 également donc il a
été mêlé a été dominée donc le bon
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il a prouvé là
aujourd'hui
à son âge il a fait une belle carrière
bon ils perdent sur une défaite c'est
vrai que c'est sur le plan de l'orgueil
c1 c'est quelque chose qu'on acceptera
maintenant bon après il ya la barrière
de l'âge et il ya des boxeurs qui lui
sont supérieures moi je pense que la
sagesse aussi à cet âge là il faudra la
sagesse dont la sagesse et puis aussi se
dire que 20 safin il vaut mieux voilà
c'est fini parce que on a été dominés
raul guti être être notre spécialiste
boxe qu'est ce que vous en pensez
fin de carrière non maintenant il faut
il faut reconnaître que la catégorie
super mi moyens c'est une catégorie très
relevée parce que dans les trois
premiers mondiaux on a quand même george
grosz calme ou smith qu'il avait déjà
rencontré mais qu'il a perdu dans un
contre
christophe junior dès le titre mondial
pour moi il est il va être très
compliqué à obtenir parce que la
catégorie est relevé mais l'âge on
produit on fait on voit de plus en plus
de d'athlètes durée dans le temps et est
très très bien se maintenir
parce que physiquement on arrive à être
en meilleure condition à se maintenir et
et la faculté a dit là il est très
surprenant parce qu'il a une faculté
quand même à revenir de et à se relever
d'une défaite qui est très surprenante
quand il a perdu au contre contre contre
calme smith
il a quand même récupéré 520 euros voilà
dès le premier round oui et donc voilà
donc rien rien de mieux rien de pire
pour pour perdre le moral et faut voir
la manière dont il a expédié christophe
rey brasser fin 2017 pour récupérer sa
ceinture il est encore capable de la
récupérer le titre mondial je crois pas
mes fans carrière non non pas fan des
états sont ni diable c'était quelqu'un à
craindre un pareil il a boxé au
vélodrome de saint quentin il a battu à
kimball qui naquit un grand boxeur
yvelinois aussi ça a été une boucherie
donc il était à redouter ce garçon là
meurent au combat pour lui ça c'est sûr
mais
en général a dit là est très très
performant dans les revanche parce que
c'est quelqu'un de très stratégique qui
s'exposent peu il peut durer parce que
c'est pas que c'est pas un boxeur qui
souffrent des combats il est peu touché
et il sait mettre en place des
stratégies pour vraiment amélioré sa box
et prendre des revanches donc le sont le
riz match est à suivre
et si vous pensez qu'à 37 ans
physiquement il peut encore tenir
je peux alors la fin je peux rien
ajouter après ce qui a été dit parce que
je tout à fait d'accord avec les deux et
puis du coup toute nuance avec tout ce
que tu sais moi j'aurais tendance à dire
que 37 ans à la base c'est déjà la fin
de carrière après voilà pour ne plus
espérer l'organisme aussi de faire de la
boxe jusqu'à 40 45 ans on a on a dépassé
le stade des performances après
effectivement on peut se maintenir
federer dans un autre domaine le prouve
mais bon voilà ça dépend aussi du mental
effectivement mais je tendrais quand
même à dire que bon 37 ans a le mental
donc c'est possible
pour moi ce qu'il a envie d'aller boxer
dix ans et vous pensez que mohammedi va
accepter cette revanche
logiquement ça devrait être signé est ce
que georges vous pensez que ce serait
dans son optique de de signer cette
revanche écoute il ya le titre mondial
qui lui tend les bras finalement la
mairie doué perdre cette possibilité
mais moi je pense que c'est ce que j'ai
essayé d'exprimer tout à l'heure déjà il
faut qu'on lui donne sa chance alors si
mauvais dit lui laisse cette chance là
je pense qu'il a la demande et ouais
d'accord a dit la police attendait et
les promoteurs sont en train de voir
éventuel nouveau quoi déjà c'est pas
c'est pas dans l'antre entre ses mains
les gens donc si les promoteurs l'ue
acceptent ce comment ce combat qui qui
qui se prépare qui le qu'ils le fassent
et qu'ils montrent qu'ils prouvent ce
qu'il veut prouver parce que moi pour
moi quand on arrive à cet âge là et
qu'on pour moi on a déjà prouvé
on a déjà prouvé même si on a pas on a
pas on a prouvé sa longévité
on a prouvé son talent on dit pas que
c'est un mauvais boxeur et je pense
aussi que comment y retourner au combat
avec le même type i takita battue et
aujourd'hui je sais que je les boxeurs
sont de plus en plus précoces quoi ils
sont précoces les techniques
d'entraînement sont encore plus c'est
aussi nous se mettre en danger
ça me semble être engagé parce que c'est
un garçon qui a quand même qui mérite
qui mérite le respect de sortir par la
grande porte et qui nous dit la
prochaine fois il sortira pas par la
grande porte ça se trouve là ils sont
pleins et sort grandie mais s'il sort
par k o
est ce que cette revanche là on sortira
sur une mauvaise image
ah oui vous vous y croyez pas du tout à
cette revanche côté j'espère c'est un
énorme danger pour pour nijat bhl que
d'accepter une revanche
j'espère qu'elle aura lieu mais je vois
pas comment à moins que in parce qu'il
ya aussi l'argent qui rentre en compte
un mois vraiment il ya l'argent enfin je
vois pas les a largement dominé quand
même a dit là où il l'a dit sur ce
combat là ils ont aimé le tête que le
projet reste riders qui si il est il est
10 h ils se connaissent tous très très
bien on le monde de la boxe en france et
passive à ce que ça par rapport à
d'autres continents
donc ils se connaissent tous et je pense
que vraiment un deal à c'est pas c'est
pas le boxeur qu'on a envie de
rencontrer dans une revanche
et en plus ils requins d'intérêt
stratégique pour prôner diable de le
faire donc j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait
lieu parce que je suis à fond derrière
adil hakiki un poulain de la même salle
que je fréquente donc il ya aussi un
côté un peu supporters mais j'y crois
pas trop
je serais très surpris en tous les cas
pareil pour bojan oui c'est pour moi
c'est un risque
un risque inutile 6e mais un risque
il se vit mais j'ai un risque inutile
pour lui mais c'est une chance pour adil
hamouma dit bien sûr oui non mais là on
parle on parle du perdant donc lui bien
sûr que lui c'est sa seule chance de
pouvoir avoir la possibilité de pouvoir
de pour son créditeur mondial alors que
l'autre baïla en affaires il va avoir il
vivait avant la porte ouverte
voilà mes djibo avait dit naji ben voilà
on continue à parler de boxe et d'ahmed
el moussaoui originaire de la verrière
il n'a pas fait de détail lors de sa
première sortie de l'année ce 24 mars au
palais des sports de marseille elvinois
a signé la 28e victoire de sa carrière
contre le hongrois gabor gorbicz dans
une confrontation 8 secondes
les juges ont tous déclaré vainqueur aux
points ce résultat permet aux boxeurs de
se maintenir à la 19e place mondiale
dans la catégorie des poids mi-moyens
ahmed el moussaoui pour être combattre
d'ici le début de l'été la question sur
ce thème
ahmed el moussaoui doit-il combattre
rapidement pour le titre mondial
lui il n'a pas trente sept ans il a 28
ans oui ou non
est-ce qu'il doit combattre rapidement
d'essayer
oui enfin petit duféal entre vous deux
encore entre entre jean et jorge lorenzo
georges alesi alesi gens n'ont même pas
trop de politesse alesi georges
oui bah écoute 28 ans 28 ans 28 ans donc
28 ans c'est l'âge d'or pour moi c'est
l'âge de la maturité c'est dans beaucoup
de sports
on est à 28 ans on est on est on est mûr
on connaît un connaisseur boxe on
connait son ne connaissez pas son
potentiel on y connait son vais enfin on
est en plein de l'essentiel on ascension
sur le plan
physique technique et mental on se
connaît son corps et je pense que là
étant donné qu'il est sur une bonne
lancée n'a pas connu de il n'a pas connu
de d'échec pour moi il faut voilà tant
qu'on est dans une bonne lancée et il
vaut mieux continuer parce qu'on a la
confiance on a on a les feux les feux
sont sont les planètes sont bien alignés
pour lui moi personnellement je serai
son coach où je serai son entourage
j'opterais pour pour ce choix-là gens
alors des côtes et il est sur une bonne
dynamique effectivement il est en pleine
confiance
peut-être un peu trop faut faire
attention et je crois qu'un championnat
du monde ça se prépare
non seulement physiquement physiquement
il a l'air très très près très affûté on
l'a vu il fait pareil dans les campeurs
mai mais un championnat du monde
bien sûr le best-of de phone really la
futaie le type de copains je crois que
jamais été comme ça de ma vie moi ouais
ils sont les intimes est un genre j'ai
été bousculé mais pas comme ça mais
c'est vrai que ce serait pour moi et je
plane ça se prépare
et ça se prépare non seulement
physiquement mais mentalement aussi
et il faudrait pas que ce que justement
cet élan de confiance lui soit fatale
sur sur ce cette conquête du titre
mondial
voilà pourquoi je suis un petit peu
réservés n'essayez comment ça se prépare
un combat de ce type commencent à en
parler ça se prépare sur de longs mois
est-ce que ça se prépare activement sur
de nombreuses semaines de l'ombre bah
oui oui mais après je suis pas non plus
spécialiste en boxe michael c'est un
petit peu délicat vivement est-ce qu'il
faut il faut quand même
eux se préparaient pour donc semaine va
quand même en général ils ont toute
l'année que quand même très physique
avec très peu de récup c'est plutôt
l'inversé
ils ont du mal à trouver du temps de
récupération non dans la sueur leur
année si quelqu'un comme à lille comme
comme amel il va faire trois combats par
an maximum donc ça va et encore il a
fait un le combat c'est un combat mise
en chauffe il a fait un virage contre le
321ème mondiale donc ce combat là
c'était juste pour le mettre en
condition mais en général ils sont la
récup qu'il faut ces accords est allé et
je pense que ce soit une question en
tout cas je pense qu'il est prêt pour
l'entraînement pendant que oui oui moi
je pense que c'est possible
raul finalement vous le disais c'était
peut-être un combat de mise en jambes
jusqu'à un vrai combat bien sûr un
championnat du monde
et de toute façon je pense qu'il faut
pas qu'ils se délient il faut qu'il
fasse très attention parce que lui en
pareil il est dans une catégorie où il
ya des extra-terrestres williams manny
pacquiao a pas raccrocher les gants
il a alors il y là il a le potentiel
faut savoir que une de ses rares
défaites elle est contre jeff orr numéro
un mondial bien sûr mais pour l'instant
c'est dans la gueule du monde en salle
en mai 2003 la daille se jetterait dans
la gueule du loup ça serait beaucoup
trop tôt à ce niveau là de toute façon
physiquement ils sont tous très préparé
et il faut pas oublier que la boxe au
delà du physique c'est quand même un
sport très technique et bien ce niveau
là c'est vraiment ce facteur qui change
donc je crois que là il faut quand même
attendre un vrai niveau de maturité
avant de se lancer dans dans un
championnat du monde 6e laisse trois en
trois ans je pense que c'est la bonne
durée quand te rendre les petits papiers
de la wb eux on en ressort aussi vite
une défaite et on évite liés aux
oubliettes surtout quand on a le malheur
alors là il est marocain mais c'est un
franco marocain
on est c'est très difficile de rentrer
dans ce dossier d'organisation là quand
on n'est pas sur le continent américain
donc faire très attention à ça faut pas
qu'ils soient pressés
ça serait bien justement qu'on arrive à
garder ce boxeur là elle faire mûrir
correctement pour qu'on pût parce que
lui je pense que potentiellement il
pourrait être champion du monde
vu ce qu'on lui a volé son ca sa
ceinture contre l'espagnol il ya un peu
moins d'un an lacunes qu'il avait mis ko
12e ceferino me semble-t-il c'est ça
voilà juste car je voulais en venir là
pierre chevallier qu'envoie finalement
les opportunités que ahmed el moussaoui
a eu pour des titres mondiaux il s'est
toujours raté on peut le dire il a perdu
contre ceferino rodriguez en décembre
2016 pour le titre européen vacant ebu
il avait perdu contre jeff orr ne vous
en parliez tout à l'heure raul pour le
titre intercontinental en mai à 2015 un
boxeur qui aujourd'hui du coup champion
du monde quand vous le disais
précédemment il avait battu manny
pacquiao notamment pour un pour le titre
de champion du monde
ça joue aussi dans la tête il peut être
pas encore prêt à 28 ans à pierre
chevalier
c'est surtout ça j'en parlais de gens
parler de mental
raul parler de technique il ya une
dimension très nette de maturité dans ce
noble à qu'est la boxe et le jeter trop
tôt dans la gueule du loup comme disait
comme disait raul c'est sûrement gâcher
un potentiel parce qu'il faut qu'il faut
qu'il monte à 28 victoires 3 défaites un
nul
il faut voir les et les adversaires
qu'il a eu jusqu'à maintenant sur sur le
combat dont on vient de parler c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt pas dire à faire
valoir mais une mise en valeur de ceux
de ce jeune champion et son potentiel et
après de pouvoir le faire monter
tranquillement mais sûrement vers un peu
plus de maturité de techniques physiques
et on n'a pas besoin mais de les
expliquer maturité ça sera le mot de la
fin sur ce thème
le haut rhinois doit partir en
compétition du coup raul vous laisse
voilà pour la deuxième partie d'émission
ne serait pas là non vous reverra sur
une prochaine émission
merci beaucoup au revoir c'est la fin de
ce coup de projecteur
ouais ouais il passe devant la caméra il
ne respecte plus rien raul c'est la fin
de ce coup de projecteur on passe
maintenant notre focus du jour
dans notre focus du football le 15e
trophée gol de letra créé par l'ancien
footballeur du paris saint-germain rail
était organisée ce samedi 24 mars au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le tournoi
caritatif a permis de récolter des dons
en faveur des enfants et des adolescents
défavorisés brésilien le tout dans une
ambiance festive brésilienne sur le
terrain de futsal les aficionados du psg
ont pu revoir des joueurs qui ont marqué
et travées du parc des princes comme
laurent fournier eric rabesandratana ou
bernard mendy on écoute les réactions
tout simplement parce que c'est une
bonne initiative
j'ai été content que rhymes appelle un
ancien de la maison et c'est pour une
bonne cause
au travers d'un match on arrive à
récolter des fonds à rassembler aussi
beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes et
c'est vrai que ce sont bien sûr bien
c'est pas grand chose c'est qu'une
journée on donne de nous sur un terrain
on se retrouve également entre anciens
footballeurs autre ancien parisien
une dizaine d'anciennes gloires qui a eu
du mal à terminer la rencontre
physiquement mais l'essentiel était
ailleurs pour cette quinzième édition
on écoute le fondateur raj au micro de
nicolas landry très productive c'était
tous les bus étaient atteints pour viser
les choses des sociétés et les
partenaires les collaborateurs aussi par
l'intégration le trophée gol de letra
devrait revenir l'année prochaine à
saint quentin en yvelines la question
sur ce thème les matches caritatifs sont
ils une piste à explorer pour remplir ce
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
oui ou non ou était georges vous pouvez
prendre
voilà super vous êtes tous d'accord
genre pourquoi parce que c'est ce qu'on
a dit plusieurs fois ici n'importe quel
événement qui amène du monde est
toujours bon pour une structure sportive
et à l'occurrence le vélodrome donc là
c'était au caritatif mécary tête il faut
pas ça a mené du monde
il vient passer une bonne journée dans
une ambiance brésilienne très très bien
donc forcément forcément c'est toujours
un plus pour pour les équipements et
toutes les structures sportives de
n'importe quel département
tu as eu un celi le coeur et les jambes
c'est lié à un certain nombre de bonnes
valeurs qui change un petit peu dans le
calendrier d'un dans dans un site qui
reçoit des compétitions sportives et là
en l'occurrence et avec avec les l'image
estampillé psg raï les anciens et puis
cette ambiance festive
du football ça sert la cause de toute
façon et est a priori un certain nombre
d' yvelinois ont été sensibles justement
à 7 à cette cause là ils remplissent le
vélodrome c'est de toute façon une
enceinte comme celle là doit vivre doit
vivre par le sport elle doit vivre par
départ des heures par des événements
festifs caritatif
si en plus c'est lier l'utile à
l'agréable c'est parfait c'est ce qu'il
faut viser en le gros point positif vous
en parlait justement ça a été l'ambiance
dans ce vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le collectif
ultras du psg investi à les tribunes
pour soutenir leurs anciens joueurs raï
regardez cet extrait
mais c'est super ambiance au web on est
certain de bin ouais non c'est bien et
puis ça permet quand même de faire
découvrir le vélodrome à ceux qui sont
allés participer à l'événement parce que
je pense qu'il connaissait pas tous donc
celle ci ressemble un public oui voilà
donc oui pour toutes ces raisons citées
et puis le fait de faire découvrir le
vélodrome aux gens des alentours et puis
par un petit peu plus loin georges gomis
oui l'enceinte aussi grande
aussi belle et aussi chaleureuse bon
c'est comme le disent mes collègues
c'est faux le faut la faire vivre et là
c'est un événement comme ça caricative
comme ils disent et plus c'est un grand
monsieur comme que moi il ya avec un
grand talent un grand coeur a mené le
brésil à saint quentin avec et amener le
psg à saint quentin emmené le public
les déplacés dans les yvelines dans
cette enseigne
on remerciera et on remercie la région
phare le département on remercie les les
toutes les personnes qui sont venues
pour servir cette cause là voilà on
aurait aimé y être nous aussi
malheureusement on avait d'autres choses
à faire et vous étiez sur les terres
encore la vérité sur les terres gens ça
permet également de faire de faire
parler du vélodrome nouvelle fois à
travers des joueurs comme que tout
supporter du psg connaît forcément voilà
eric rabesandratana rail ou bernard
mendy différentes échelles 1 forcément
mais voilà ça a permis de faire parler
du vélodrome à travers des joueurs qui
ont marqué l'histoire du club
ben oui forcément fort ça on a envie de
jouer autre chose s'est déplacé un plus
une population qui est pas du tout lié
à la structure qu'est le vélodrome c'est
du football qui arrive là avec en plus
un public du psg qui est qu'un pas qui
est des fois papa super donc là c'est
très très bien parce qu'on a vu le bon
côté aussi du public et on montre
souvent le mauvais côté des supporters
du psg et là on voit quand même qu'il
n'ya pas que des mauvais supporters au
psg ont heureusement d'ailleurs parce
que là mais on a trop tendance
malheureusement montré que le mauvais
live et le beau c'était le côté festif
le côté convivial les joueurs jouent le
jeu des belles des baux longs des beaux
joueurs une belle manifestation
bravo ça sera le mot de la fin pour la
deuxième fois je crois dans cette
émission pour vous sur cette thématique
ça sent la fin
nous allons maintenant arrêter de parler
de ballon rond pour parler à ballon
ovale je vous propose un focus sur
fabien vite ce jeune rugbyman de 17 ans
originaire de saint quentin en yvelines
a connu sa première sélection en équipe
de france de rugby des moins de 18 ans
une première consécration pour fabien
qui a réalisé ses premiers à plaquage
l'âge de quatre ans au club du mesnil
saint denis et revient sur ses débuts
dans les yvelines au micro de nicolas
doré j'étais très très actif est un
petit donc c'est tout ce qui est enfin
je pense cette décharge d'énergie qui ma
femme qui m'a fait plaisir qui m'a je
sentais que j'étais dans mon est en fait
d
de tout petit je sentais que ça me
plaise novembre alors ce jeune mesure 2
m pour 104 kg à 17 ans il est donc
deuxième ligne la question sur ce thème
at il le profil type du rugbyman moderne
oui ou non un grand oui on va faire
parler les spécialistes genre pourquoi
vous essayez entre ouais c'est non parce
que c'est vrai que bon dans quelques
années on a pris une dizaine de kilos et
4 cm je crois pas de différence sur des
gabarits des joueurs c'est vrai que il y
en a de plus en plus quand même des
jeunes de cet âge là avec des
manipulations comme ça et là beaucoup
hélas énormément
pour lui ben c'est bien après mon équipe
nationale des moins de 18 ans et les
moins de 18 qu'il faut falloir qu'ils
continuent à agrandir peut-être
pentagone talent puisque c'est bien
d'avoir incorporé une équipe nationale à
son âge après il faut il faut il faut
durer il faut durer là dedans et est-ce
que c'est l'avenir devoir prendre la
masse musculaire pour continuer voilà
tout à fait est-ce que c'est l'avenir
ça dépend du poste aussi parce que lui
là c'était secondes de ligne ont
peut-être troisième missile est adroit
et intelligent là est la cub ont ils
vont et on m'attaquait mais c'est
malheureusement c'est vrai et c'est
c'est vrai aussi que
le fait que ce poste là mais il faut des
certaines certaine maturation entre
guillemets mais tout le monde fait pas
de mettre aujourd'hui et heureusement
et encore même au niveau international
équipe de france à
il y avait des joueurs tout le monde ils
font pas tous de m et avant de donner il
faudra peut-être aussi regarder au
niveau des gabarits et des l'intensité
des des matchs et surtout les chocs de
plus en plus violent un parliez
justement cette assez physique et qu'ils
soient de plus en plus impressionnant
clair j dans ceux-ci leur brouille a le
profil type
oui oui là il a le profil type parce que
c'est pour un deuxième ligne faire plus
de deux mètres et surtout surtout de
faire plus du quintal mois sont
inchangés c'est à dire c'est que c'est
plus rare parce que j'ai un constat en
dix ans je fais un constat en disant que
les générations de nos enfants sont
seront de toute façon nous mangerons sur
la tête parce qu'ils seront plus grand
plus filer en plus physique plus
physiques que nous serons peut-être
mieux nourris que d'os manière dont pour
l'été nous on a pris plus en largeur
qu'en hauteur ils prennent les deux donc
ça c'est produit constatent le deuxième
c'est c'est une question c'est est ce
que le rugby va rester un sport de ce
qu'il est devenu un sport de collisions
et non plus un sport de contact si on
est dans cette dans cette veine là oui
un deuxième ligne de 2 m et 104 kg à 17
ans ça va faire à peu près 120 bombe a
20 ans quand il sera quand il sera
vraiment en pleine maturité
donc oui là il a le physique de
déménageur marques ont par contre c est
ce que est ce que le rugby va rester au
delà de au delà du contact n'est
vraiment sûr la collision ou est-ce
qu'il va redevenir un sport d'évitement
et esquive là il est quand même il est
quand même dans la norme parce que ce
que ce qu'on voyait sur les images c'est
que même avec 2 m
et 104 kg il fait des passes vi et de 10
mètres des deux côtés a priori pour un
deuxième miss est assez rare notre
génération avec jean on n'a pas trop
connu ça les deuxièmes lignes touchées
pas beaucoup les ballons là il est il
est athlétique il al'air technique
donc oui c'est le prototype du joueur de
rugby moderne non est-ce qu'il va ce
qu'il va se fondre à l'évolution de
notre jeu dans les années à venir
justement et c'est vous d'abord misé sur
l'évitement plutôt que la puissance chez
les joueurs de rugby
c'est le pari qu'ils aient pris part par
un certain nombre de clubs dont rugby
club international également c'est à
dire que maintenant on en revient un
petit peu de d'envoyer des autobus ce
tamponnais se tamponner à tout voir au
centre du terrain et on est on est plus
à espérer le retour du fait du french
flair et puis de 2,7 de ce jeu de passes
des skiffs de crochet avec des avec des
gabarits qui sont ils sont pas tous
comme comme ce jeune fabien vite et dont
il continue dont il faut utiliser les
talents et les les qualités et on a on
n'a pas que des on n'a pas que des
quintaux qui joue un qui joue au rugby
il ya aussi des grands qui sont plutôt
fin et qu'ils sont capable justement
d'éviter et de faire faire vivre le
ballon au monde de faire chanter le cuir
georges justement les de nombreuses
équipes nationales notamment la nouvelle
zélande joue avec cette technique
d'évitement plutôt maintenant puisque de
contact est-ce que c'est l'avenir du du
rugby c'était la particularité du fait
du rugby français à la base qui était
qui et et angers on loue et de le rugby
français
ces îlots phrase flair il disait on
parlait que de ça est bon maintenant
c'est vrai qu'on est dans un
on a voulu copier on a laissé un peu
l'identité du rugby français en ayant
des idées des autres puisqu'ils ont
tamponné qui vont tant qu'elle est là
aujourd'hui si 6e la fédération
française et le directeur technique
national décide de repartir
comment sur une autre base technique je
pense que les français vont être
contents parce que les français c'est
les amateurs du beau rugby il aime le
rugby mais le beau rugby
et là c'est vrai que moi personnellement
je regarde les matches mais de enfin là
je reviens un peu au rugby à la
télévision mais un moment je regarde
failli à deux ans je regardais moi parce
que c'était c'était beaucoup intercepte
ça se joue et aux coups de pied arrêtés
et aux chocs au rock et aux compagnies
donc si on revient ce rugby là bas moi
je serais enchanté
on va revenir à fabien vite est-ce qu'il
peut encore prendre de la masse
musculaire leslie la 17 ans oui bah
alors là justement ces bons scores
il va faire que ça je pense de lettres
104 kg je le rappelle pour allaiter
spectateurs ouais là la bonne
morphologie
on peut estimer qu'il est en dos
mais au morfond 10 mai aux morts et aux
aubrais
ouais mais oui effectivement après 6 et
s'ils jouent pas dans une stratégie
c'est un diamant sais quoi mais au fait
qui va développer facilement sa masse
musculaire à toute manière on doit bien
prendre soin d'eux qu'ils mangent pas
assez pour pour favoriser avril à
regarder au pôle espoir de lakanal de
sceaux ouais ouais il encadre au moins
voilà mais par contre
sa taille c'est un inconvénient avec les
blessures par contre parce que ça
augmente le phénomène de bras de levier
en fait il ya plus de tension sur toutes
ses articulations
quand ils courent donc voilà c'est à
double tranchant un petit peu le rugby
est devenu trop traumatisant de votre
avis basque entier à la masse musculaire
qui va avec
et avec un comment dire une formes
trapues c'est mieux et puis après plus
on devient grand plus on est fragile au
au cou il ya un retour chez les pros et
chez les grands il ya un retour du dd
rupture des ligaments croisés antérieurs
notamment ya eu coup sur coup trois de
suite au niveau des joueurs de top 14
que ce soit avec l'équipe de france avec
leur équipe de club entre dupont
paillaugue et brice dulin pour le racing
ces sondes et sont des pros qui sont
normalement très entraînés et qui sont
prêts justement à 7
à ce jeu d'évitement et qui se cassent
tout seul sur un sur un crochet et le lc
apps est le contact n'est pas forcément
la cause de tous ces plats sont pas la
cause c'est peut-être la préparation au
contact futur et donc au match fut
turquie et qui explique une certaine
fragilisation de la partie tendon et et
les muscles et c'est un peu inquiétant
de ce côté là parce que si les pros
largement préparée à l'exercice sont
soumis à ce genre de blessure qui sont
qui étaient des suites des blessures
spécifique de footballeur mais qui sont
aussi maintenant d'aider blessure
spécifique de skieurs ou de rugbyman
effectivement maintenant le les chocs
les chocs et des contacts qui sont plus
après sur les sur les acromio et
surveillés sur les sur les commotions
cérébrales qui est un autre débat au 6
mai
oui il ya une petite petite inquiétude
là dessus il faut être prêt physiquement
pour le pôle le rugby actuel maintenant
espérons que qu'il évoluera dans le bon
sens vers l'évitement g où justement
vous citez la définition du rugby dans
le dictionnaire sport collectif de
combat il d'évitement
c'est ça jean yves phaneuf indirects et
donc revenir à l'évitement et dans le
dictionnaire vous voulez tout à fait
dresser la base et c'est la définition
volet ne citer qu'eux tout à fait juste
et pour en revenir à fabien vite l'a vu
son jeune âge et ses manipulations à
l'impressionnante il aurait intérêt à
être très très bien encadré justement
pour éviter pour éviter ces pièges et et
de deux malheureusement ce se casser
rapidement parce que il est quand même
il est quand même jeune et en pleine
croissance même si qu'il est qu'il
annonce plus de 2 m et 104 kg justement
justement il va falloir qu'ils soient
très très bien encadrés pour éviter pour
éviter que dans sa croissance qui n'est
pas terminée il plie le corps prennent
de mauvaises habitudes et kiki qui se
répercute serait beaucoup plus tard ou
même un peu plus tard dans sa carrière
pas quand il aura ses gains de taille
fera comme tous les anciens joueurs de
rugby il sera mauvais vieux mauvais mais
s'ils ont quand même il a intérêt à
faire très attention être très suivi de
très près lakanal de sceaux c'est
le pôle idéal pour lui oui oui on qu'on
connaît bien les entraîneurs qui sont là
qui sont là bas qui est notamment il ya
eu notamment wesley fofana qui est
passée par là mathieu bastareaud
également un atout et pas mal
d'internationaux ils sont beaux et qui
sont passés d'un raid et des joueurs
franciliens qui sont passés à l'as
cannes avant d'en avant d'avoir des
belles carrières internationales
effectivement c'est un bel écrin où
justement les choses sont faites pour
pouvoir accompagner les jeunes sur le
chemin du professionnalisme pour
certains mais ont en tout cas sur le sur
le sur la progression vers le vers le
haut niveau
en intégrant tous ces paramètres de plus
en plus technique mais justement pour
pouvoir les faire grandir quasiment avec
tuteur en fait c'est le fait d faire
grandir sur les sur une courbe qui sont
doués qui sur une coupe qui est de plus
en plus impressionnante mais avec
justement justement préparation et ils
sont on le souhaite le meilleur en tout
cas c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouvent le jeudi 19 avril pour une
nouvelle émission va terminer par une
citation de l'ancien pilote de formule 1
le légendaire ayrton senna
idéalement nous sommes ce que nous
pensons dans la réalité nous sommes ce
que nous accomplissons je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv à 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]